so the topic of money in politics has
surged back to the forefront
particularly in the context of the
upcoming midterm elections and also
because of Trump's attorney Michael
Cohen just receiving literally millions
of dollars to peddle influence of Donald
Trump to for-profit companies including
AT&T and Novartis and others that were
learning about so today for the classic
interview of the week we're going back
to my interview with Ben Cohen of Ben
and Jerry's Fame who has made really one
of his primary political issues getting
money out of politics it was great to
talk to him the topic of ice cream
didn't really come up too much although
it did a little bit let's go back to my
interview with Ben Cohen from July of
2015 on a topic that we've been talking
about it for years and were sadly no
closer to solving it I would argue than
we were back in 2015 it's a pleasure to
be joined today by Ben Cohen co-founder
of the great Ben & Jerry's and also head
Stamper at stamp stampede which is
working to get money out of politics
reduce the influence of big money in the
political system this is such an
important issue I've been talking about
this for years and finally more people
are discussing it you've been worried
about money in politics for a long time
that would be correct yeah you know I
mean clearly it's the the gateway drug
to all that's wrong with our political
system I mean you know no matter what
issue you're interested in whether it's
the environment or education or housing
or taxes or Wall Street or student debt
they all have their roots in
corporations and the wealthiest 0.01%
bribing our politicians through campaign
donations to pass or not pass laws that
benefit them and screw everybody else
that's exactly right and I've even
talked to people who say well David you
know it's money in politics but it's
also media coverage of whatever issue
you're talking about to which I say well
but money is influencing the coverage we
see in media so it really is money no
matter what it really is money no matter
what I mean this is a system that john
mccain has called legalized bribery
it's totally corrupt politicians are
doing the bidding not of the voters but
of the people who finance their
campaigns I don't know if you saw a
recent study from Princeton but it
actually seek to analyze whether we
really have a sort of representative
democracy in other words is the mean of
the desires of the average voter
actually represented by our elected
officials and it turned out in fact
exactly what you're saying is true if
you're a big corporation or you're a
wealthy individual your legislative
desires are far more likely to become
the law than if you're just the average
individual with a mean income the
average income in this country so quite
literally we don't really have a level
playing field that's exactly right
and like you say the study that you're
talking about proves it
the people with the money get what they
want everybody else doesn't and talk to
me a little bit about how what paths
forward we have on this because we
sometimes hear from political candidates
oh I will reform campaign finance or
I'll change the status quo but
ultimately if they get elected they were
elected under that status quo system
they came to power under that system
there's not a very strong incentive for
them to actively work to change the
system that got them into power is there
yeah I think the only thing that's
really gonna work here is public demand
you know there's all the gridlock in
Congress there's all the [ __ ] that
goes on there but the reality is that
when the public really demands something
Congress has to act and that's what the
stampede is about is showing visible
wall
lasting grassroots public demand to get
money out of politics and return our
country to a democracy and I want to
talk about the stamps and stamp stampede
but before we do that you know one of
the one of the specific paths forward
that stamp stampede has identified is
this possibility of a constitutional
amendment which declares two things one
money money is not free speech and two
corporations are not people and our
friend Tom Hartman has been talking
about this and our friends at the Young
Turks have been talking about this is
this really a viable path forward not in
the sense that would it work if it
happened but rather is it realistic to
think it could be achieved yeah I think
it's definitely realistic it's a
long-term goal I mean I think it's
probably gonna take about ten years for
this amendment to pass you know it's
notable that 16 states have already
voted in favor of an amendment to the
Constitution to get money out of
politics there's currently major effort
underway in Arkansas which would be the
first state in the south to pass a
resolution like that and there's another
effort in the state of Washington so
it's it's moving it's gathering momentum
I mean it's kind of amazing that seven
of the presidential candidates have all
spoken out in favor of this amendment
but there's also things that can be done
until the amendment that's paid gets
passed and that is to pass legislation
on both the state and federal level that
is essentially a small donor matching
system so that candidates agree to just
take money from small donors and then
the money that they raise is matched six
to one and that's enough for candy
dates to opt-in to that system so laws
like that are on the books currently in
Connecticut Arizona Maine is about to
strengthen theirs
and also in the city of New York and
this is really the nitty-gritty of why
local politics matters so much because
you can you it's much easier as an
individual to influence what happens at
your local level then maybe which
senator is elected in your state or
certainly who the president is and at
that same local level you can actually
achieve some pretty big wins with regard
to money and politics and the ways
you're describing yeah it's also
important to point out that about 650
municipalities passed resolutions in
favor of this amendment and that effort
is ongoing and that's the kind of thing
that puts pressures on states to pass
state-level legislation and then puts
pressure on the federal government to
pass federal legislation last thing I
want to talk about and then we'll get
into the specifics of Stamp stampede is
it important to in conjunction to be
lobbying for the types of change you're
talking about legislatively to also be
supporting financially alternatives to
the sort of status quo corporate media
because lots of alternative media
including Tom Hartman including our
program etc are very proactively talking
about this issue but this issue is
barely mentioned on the advertiser
driven corporate media so is that also a
valuable way to sort of influence this
discussion I think it's incredibly
important yeah it's it's amazing to me
how little the corporate media reports
on the most important issues that are
facing us I mean the corporate media is
pretty much reporting a bunch of gossip
a bunch of gotcha journalism but you
know titillating stuff like what you
might find in the National
choir but they're not talking about the
real issues and and it's really
interesting that the corporate media is
being eclipsed by the alternative media
on the web alright let's talk about
Stamp stampede people can find out more
at Stamp stampede organ part of this
initiative is literally to be stamping
money with a message to get money out of
politics that's right we just crossed
the fifty thousand Stamper threshold you
know this is although it's totally legal
to to stamp paper currency you know
everybody was brought up with the idea
that you can't to face money but the
reality is that when you look at the
actual federal regulation they describe
defacing as obliterating the currency so
that it can no longer be used and that's
certainly not what we're doing here's a
picture can you see this photo of a
stamp dollar bill yes indeed can you
read was it said not to be used for
bribing politicians exactly and so we've
also got other stamps that say stamp
money out of politics or not to be used
for buying elections and it's so
powerful I mean it's very similar to an
alternative media because this is the
original viral marketing as as money
gets passed around once you put a dollar
into circulation
875 people see it as it gets passed
around over the next two and a half
years which is the lifespan of the bill
and you know the numbers are amazing I
mean one person stamping three bills a
day for a year
generates a million impressions one
person
literally a million impressions in a
year just by stamping three bills a day
and you know it's it's pretty easy it's
pretty quick and you know it's kind of
fun it is very interesting and people
can find out more and get the stamps at
Stamp Stampede org before we let you go
we're of course speaking with yeah go
ahead that air during the month of July
absolutely well July in honor of the
birth of our nation is pay what you can
month at the stamp stampede so you just
go to stamp stamp each org
and what maybe I need to give you a link
or something I think if you contact Edie
we'll make sure to put it up for
everybody I'll give you the link to the
pay what you can feature and you just
decide how much you want to pay for the
stamp and it's yours alright before we
let you go or of course speaking with
Ben Cohen co-founder of Ben and Jerry's
do you still consume a lot of ice cream
these days oh yes I've recently you know
I used to be a confirmed Cherry Garcia
fan oh me too and I've recently switched
and now I'm eating around and you know
I'm doing a lot of pistachio I'm doing
the new salted Carmel core and chunky
monkey what can I say I'm aging I don't
know what and do you tend is that has
that always been your thing where you're
mostly on like two or three flavors you
don't vary from that at a time well it
used to be I was just on Cherry Garcia
and before that I was just on New York
Superfudge I was on heath bar crunch
alright Ben Cohen co-founder of Ben &
Jerry's please check out stamp Stampede
org and we'll make sure to provide a
link to the pay what you can feature
that Ben told us about thank you so much
for being on and telling us about it
good talking to you David
take care